In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
The reading from the Sinaxadium for July 3 on which we commemorate the Holy Martyrs
Hyacinth and Thildota of Cessaria in Cappadocia.
On the third of the month we celebrate the memory of the Holy Martyr Hyacinth, the Chamberlain.
The Holy Martyr Hyacinth was from Cappadocia, and at the age of 18, served as Chamberlain,
Cubicularios, at the court of the Emperor Trajan.
One day, when the Emperor was celebrating his sumptuous feast in honor of the idols,
the saint went aside to pray.
One of his colleagues, called Urbisius, having noticed this, went and denounced him to the sovereign.
The Emperor, who was at table, ordered that the rebel be brought that instant, and holding
out to him food offered in sacrifice to idols, attempted to force him to eat it in front
of him.
The saint, making the sign of the cross, refused to do so, and urged the Emperor to renounce
the cult of demons, and come to know the knowledge of the One True God.
Angered by his assurance, the sovereign had him hit on the mouth, and handed him over to
the soldiers, who, having belabored him with kicks, forced his mouth open to make him swallow
the sacrificed food.
Seeing that his agents were trying in vain, Trajan furiously left the banqueting hall, giving
the order that the saint be put in prison, his feet held in a vice.
The next day, Hyacinth was taken to the amphitheater, and declared to the Emperor that no torture
could make him exchange eternal life for the pleasures of this life of misery.
The torturers thrashed him with such violence that their faces were covered in his blood,
and when they were exhausted, they stretched him on a rack to last-rate his sides.
Overcoming the suffering by the overflowing of his love for God, the saint cried out,
O Trajan, you are without wishing to, giving me the greatest of benefits in teaching me to endure
the sufferings of Christ, the more cruel your tortures, the greater my faith will be.
He endured the torturers for seven hours at the end of which he was returned to prison.
The Emperor ordered that he be given no food other than that offered to idols which they
placed before him every day.
Turning away in disgust from this sign of worship of demons, the valiant athlete of Christ
remained without food or drink for many days, nourished only by his faith and by prayer.
On the thirty-eighth day, the chief jailer, who had just put the usual food in front of him,
saw a brilliant light shining in the cell where the saint was standing, his face radiant, flanked by two
angels. Dropping the food, he went at ones to report the matter to the Emperor, who, believing that he
was hallucinating, commanded that Hyacinth be put to further torture. On the forty-eighth day,
when the jailers came to fetch him to appear before Trajan, they found him dead, surrounded by angels
in human form, holding candles in their hands. The tyrant in no way moved then had his body thrown
to the wild beasts on the mountain. The priest Timothy, a kinsman of the saint, was led by an angel
straight to the place where his body was lying. He was able to give it decent burial,
and when he came to die, arranged for a devout widow to take care of the precious relics.
Many years later, Saint Hyacinth appeared to a man of senatorial rank in the land,
who had just been struck by blindness. He healed him, and after having revealed to him the place
where the saint's grave was being cared for by the widow, enjoyed him to take the relics to his
homeland. But, after the healing, the man forgot his promise, and immediately began to lose his sight.
Healed once more by the saint, he obeyed, and had the body taken to Caesarea. Arriving at the
entrance to the town, the animals that were pulling the cart on which the relics were placed,
went straight to the saint's family home, where they stopped. On the same day, we commemorate the
Holy Martyrs Thildotus, Thildota, Golindach, and their companions, Diomedes, Olympus, and Esclepias.
These holy and glorious martyrs also lived during the reign of Trajan.
Having refused to sacrifice to the gods of the empire, they were put to torture and then shut
in the same prison as Saint Hyacinth, being encouraged by him to remain firm in their confession of
the faith. After Saint Hyacinth's death, as they continued to condemn the worship of idols,
they were tied to stakes and burned alive before being beheaded. And they thus carried off the palm
of victory. Their bodies were devoutly buried by Christians at the place of their martyrdom.
Through the prayers of our Holy Fathers, O Lord Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us and save us.